thank you guys for coming out tonight we
got a very special episode of strategy
session tonight
I am joined by the one and only ten West
so the mystery is finally out this is
Ken West we're going to be exploring
some of his games tonight so Ken thanks
for coming out we're gonna have a look
at some of your games and we'll see
what's what's been going on so Ken is
number number 83 he's been coming to the
club forever plays in all sorts of
tournaments and things like that and the
games that I've selected tonight are
from this month's Knights tournament so
every Wednesday you play one round and
you accumulate points over the course of
the month and at the end whoever has the
most points is the winner so so far
there's been three weeks we'll see how
many games we get through tonight and
let's see let's talk about this first
round game so we're going to throw it
over the board only if spent Symonds
ready and the first round opponent that
you had was Luke Yi the little kid 1,700
very very talented kids so he's been you
know his rating just keeps going up and
he's probably even stronger than 1,700
now so we will look at this game and we
won't talk about the the grandmasters
rating that's the big thing is Ken
really a grandmaster that's what we're
going to try to figure out tonight it's
it's unclear we'll see this and we'll
lay that the answer to that question to
rest yeah either way yeah this another
play exactly and I wish I did beat Luke
about a year ago but he was lying 1,100
yeah he's just trying to talk my way out
real fast
definitely okay so ken has the black
pieces here we'll get right to it
because we got a lot to cover tonight
all right so so far a normal opening the
Petroff so you still play this I still
play it may give it up and Luke goes
into the variation I hate against it
okay I hate that you hate this he should
take the pawn Yeah right yeah everybody
wants to take but I guess it's a good
move because he knew his opponent very
well
okay candy would have been ready for
this right so so good prep right and
maybe he did do prep because at the
nights you get analysis from the
Grandmaster so you get to see every game
that's been played so it is quite
possible he did see that okay he's gonna
play this and then I want to surprise
them with Knight to c3 so very good
choice and I think here already can
tried to play very aggressively yes
should I drop a pawn short and you play
d5 which drops a pond right away okay
but yeah it's only moved three I mean
that's it's typical um I do not like the
four Knights that's probably better I
don't know it but I usually don't know
the other either yeah cuz yeah I mean I
would just play the four Knights here is
black which is fine white maybe has a
tiny smidge Rishikesh alive yeah the
bishop comes out the castle d6 your
other Bishop comes out it's it's pretty
easy just to play even if you don't know
a lot of theory but this very
unconventional gambit the other west
gambit don't try this one at home ah he
took it and I mean I don't see anything
better I don't think efore really
accomplishes anything I think you know
like if here instead of the game I mean
I don't know what that actually
accomplished so I can just decided to to
take it overlooking the fact that the
the e5 pawn is wait to be is this what
you calculated like this capsule Tiger
Foyet detected of course and sometimes
in you on these openings so what
happened to the game was he just took
this one he just took the pawn you know
sometimes there's like efile things
where you go here and then you hope they
do something silly and then you like win
because there's a pin but I think here I
mean he can just use his Queen to block
as well only okay that's just a pawn
so after he took let's see what Ken did
I don't even remember most of this game
so okay he took and I suppose white
capture either way I can catch with my
deep on and maybe trade the Queen's but
I think this also is
perfectly reasonable and I'm upon up so
I think too there was some moments in
this game where perhaps we could come up
with some better moves because it's
tough sometimes you know you're down
upon but there's still a lot of game
left we got all the pieces and you know
there's all sorts of stuff going on here
so we'll see if can actually ever has a
chance to get some Redemption here so
okay there's 56 that make sense EF Queen
d7 doesn't work then okay I guess that's
a valid move and he just goes back it
just goes back with the pawn he's just
up upon so nicely six sure
d4 love it castles Bishop e2 and I
believe it's here I mean we don't see a
great plan for you but I guess I guess
yeah you go try to checkmate him here
you played here which I thought was a
little strange so I guess - I didn't
really want to put this bishop here just
because at some point it might get
traded and I don't really want to trade
so I guess if it were me I would have
tried to find a different square for the
bishop just because here it won't be
traded
perhaps I get some pressure on this guy
and you will see say I even kept made
way of matters worse by taking that
night with that Bishop and thank the
knights castles is it here okay okay so
you just took the night and yeah this is
a big mistake and I've seen this a lot
in a lot of knights games and then every
week the grandmasters keep saying you
know don't give up your bishops for the
night no reason and then everybody keeps
doing it I've noticed you at this
tournament the grandmasters tell you
like stop doing this and every week is
the same it's it's not just you it's
everybody everybody plays don't put a
noise on the room yeah
it doesn't matter what you do it's just
think I think all I can do is tell you
every time that just happened
why did you make this decision did you
have anything in mind I thought I saw
some a ghost where I thought I could get
some pawn back but does it happen okay
is there like some trick here is it he
took back like he thought you had some
trick maybe here right right like
picking up that h2 point somewhere
somewhere along the line but okay but no
okay all right so see so you made a
threat though right he's a little kid
baby you'll miss maybe he'll miss it um
okay he is 1700 and I think even here
two white could improve so I guess I'll
give the audience two choices here you
can play h3 or g3 those are your choices
I look at the audience involved a little
bit if you guys were faced with this
this threat of checkmate how would you
guys parry the threat also I'll give you
this third option that stops you oh I'll
show ya and you know it's the Knights
game so that's very possible I would
have liked that would have been nice I
guess but how would you guys choose to
defend against the mate here
Ben Simon Says g3 yj3 Ben Simon because
the bishop can go back to g2 right and I
guess to though in the game he played h3
and my way of thinking is when I notice
that somebody doesn't have a bishop so
you don't have a light squared bishop
I want my dark squares to be really
strong so I would play if it'll let me
the move g3 which strengthens the dark
squares around my king I'm obviously not
worried about weakening my light squares
not only do I have a light squared
Bishop but he actually can go back and
cover all the squares if I need them to
and also after h3 I mean obviously this
should be fine too sometimes it might be
possible like if we just choose to go
out the wrong way sometimes you might be
able to force more weaknesses so even
though that might not be possible for a
long time and you should probably be
careful not to let that happen I think
just overall g3 makes a lot of sense
strengthen the dark squares and your
dark squared Bishop looks and granite
all right but okay so here we go h3 and
now some deep prophylaxis right you
really yeah was this just because you
thought white would go here well the
computer was screaming that white should
do that I shall later but I was also
wanting to what was my plan here oh I
think it was wanting to bring my knight
back over okay it's some come in
somewhere so we're wrong here yeah okay
and did you have like a dream square so
normally I like to think about where he
should go like I'll pick him up and I'll
be like where should I go I feel like I
should be somewhere towards your King
right I don't know where I should be
maybe maybe I should be here so I don't
know maybe you could do this with your
knight
you'd have to you know not get forward
to stuff but wrong maybe that is is
ultimately the square where your knight
wants to be Oh at the other oh that's
right because I wanted to be able to
move the knight and if the rooks not
there will just be Bishop takes pawn
okay so you were over the knight suits
protecting the pond well I supposed to
he could play rugby one just to prevent
your
and smoking if he should prevent your
maneuver and then I could probably go to
a 5 min I think the nights of the rim so
you know you're right and then after
this move where are you going yeah yeah
it feels like you should be going
towards the king-size go get him over
there but I wanted to be able to move
the night and I can't without the rook
being there I lose another pawn yeah
which would not be so good and that's a
good all right so I like it
and so after this move my guess is this
where you're right in here exactly okay
rook e1 sure alright f5 so it's at least
an aggressive move I don't know what
else are you trying to control for they
worried about something are you just
gonna are you gonna go nuts here and go
like that I was throwing a kitchen shake
yeah it's like I don't applaud what can
I do
yeah we don't want to be too too
desperate I mean it's it's only a pawn
so we don't have to get so aggressive
but I mean okay maybe something like
this point for me you know if we can
play g5 but our Knight here maybe you
know you're gonna try to open up a
couple up to roll the ropes on the F
file somehow all right all right so he
made a simple thread I guess he's gonna
play c5 right to get the knight out of
the way and c5
okay so that's good I mean he's got this
extra pound over here so he's pushing
where he has a majority that makes sense
very solid pretty good for a little kid
yeah that's not like a it's not a normal
little kid move you know just a little
tiny strengthening yeah that's how
you're expecting because then that
eliminates the bishop going to f6 and
the rooks coming to d8 yeah and I got
the day with the Queen behind yeah you
just sent me to solid just go away she's
just waiting and I'll tell you where
this guy goes a little bit later just
just give me a minute I'll tell you I'll
tell you later okay so you wanted to
relieve your rook so I think that will
make sense and now a favorite plays like
d5 maybe you can take it in love
weaknesses so okay I think that move
makes sense that's a problem so that's
interesting
well at least probably coming there
exactly yeah yeah I did think you would
keep this guy here just for defense you
know I feel like this guy's pretty good
over here but I guess now he sees all
right nothing's happening here so it's
all right laundry maneuver and as long
as I don't get checkmated because like
you start to put a lot of pieces over
here so I would you know get a little
bit of hope I don't think it's anything
yet but you know maybe yeah maybe you
drift a little bit too far that way
maybe canvas comes back okay
another prophylactic move just getting
out of the way of the check and he
offers a trade of Queens course what we
get
so probably I would move my queen or
something but that's tough
you'd have to go here yeah that's I
guess I'd probably do that I take a
doctorate I think I did trade just to
get the F file over me and rape and let
go here I guess that's what I would do
probably one trade probably what you get
to if you didn't trade you just you got
your rook over there and you're lining
up with this unprotected rope so that
could be something and I did already
have a quick look at this position and
so I think here can actually miss a
really big chance there's a really
really good move for black do you know
the move so see if you can find it
before can last you can pause your your
videos Bishop takes pawn bishop takes
pawn know that discipline okay so you
have this right here just takes first
out it musha's and I've got nothing
thread and I take all your stuff right
it'll really lose ink
yeah so that's we're on the right track
there is something here to this you know
possible tactical idea and you do want
when you see stuff like this like we're
lined up this pieces aren't protected
you want to see how can I make some sort
of tactical possibility come from this
you should always yeah Bishop d6 so I
think this just would have you know
you're probably winning more Wow
so you know because if here I mean I can
take here if you take here it is
protected by my knight right so
something like this that's your bad know
about it all um let's see what other
possible moves you could if you trade
here okay I'm taking your rook with
check and so you're probably gonna get
well it's me it's me it's even better
that's even better
what else what other moles could even
even try I guess he could take this this
is one way to do it too maybe this is
the best move and then here and so he
lost in exchange and that Bishop
sniffing anywhere yeah so
but uh but yes so you're actually you
missed a chance yeah you missed a chance
to be little Lukey that well um yeah it
could have been the big turnaround right
and it just comes from trying to find
tactical ideas you know you want to
start to recognize when there's the
possibility for certain tactics and when
you you're lined up with an unprotected
piece you want to stop and you want to
try to come up with some move like this
because anywhere we move the bishop you
know R attacking an unprotected piece
and attacking the Queen bowl-shaped and
so yeah the most most forceful move
attack the Queen but sadly it was not to
be and but even okay so if you don't see
that tactic which is understandable um
why did you decide to trade the Queen's
you get the F file open to get the F
file open riches okay but do you have to
have a way to like exploit this you're
gonna push that was the idea that is
protect me I like when the F file opens
for me but not for him right um right so
this might you know then that's also a
pretty good pawn it's a decent pawn
there it has a good utility but you went
here to trade more what to also lined up
on net oh okay your three pod yeah okay
so we saw some some good Bishop
maneuvers in this game so you're going
c7 I assume when you get there he will
protect it
so you connected his rooks a trades
because he's a head he's head it's a
very interesting move so he found a
little tactical move let's let's just
play one embarrassing line that would
that be good yeah but I did see the head
you didn't see it okay I'm good and you
can you chose not to trade which I can
think is probably right and I mean okay
and it's we do have to be careful that
we have a knight here but you know
sometimes this rook is going to come
down there and it does cut us here is
each up a bunch of pawns mm-hmm so there
goes the King King is going to protect
the pond okay now to move like f4 so I
don't really know what happens on that
floor but it seems like every day they
could play here I think you would yeah
okay so instead a little extra lift
never rebels on the red wanted to get
chief g5 it okay so we need to put the
night somewhere problem is I don't know
where that somewhere but uh okay maybe
yeah maybe some low I think I just want
have what we call correctly maybe some
tidying Toofer I don't know how you're
gonna do it we'll see see what you come
up with so you protect the guy haha 9h8
a deep powerful Rhema nuvaring preparing
g5 so how you go here yeah okay you can
play g5 which he prevented like that
then you just don't get more stuff she
did nice to be pawns and okay for me
from here things kind of fell apart I
don't think there was any any moment
where yes I thought at one point it
could be a threefold repetition in there
but you know he just wants to kick over
yeah comes along this side pushes upon
and then I took that guy - yeah seems is
Mary in goodbye good night so I think we
answered one question is it was really
GN yeah so let's let's look at two
moments here so again you don't have to
that's cute
not to beat it to death but I love it we
do have this this possibility so you
want to look for these tactical ideas
and all the way back so just don't give
away upon and move through exactly
exactly in the figures the funny thing
is before I went over the computer
analysis okay I'm hanging in pretty good
yeah but you run through the computer
says no you're just along your dad you
can have like this one before
you you're getting an hour and a half of
futile yeah so so do not try the the
West gambit at home right that's not to
be recommended okay we gets then the
second round is a little bit better for
you this is Timothy Zhang we can't see
the the rating on here but I think he's
about 818 or so chicks ahead all right
Ken gets the white pieces
and guess what I play guess what he
plays so if you know Ken West you know
he plays the collie like no matter what
so that's what we're gonna see but his
opponent here played very unusual so
normally they play Knight f6 and then
Ken plays III that's that's every ken
west game right will wake you up for the
game's over right and then you know what
gets me better so it's not and I know
because we've played this before too and
as the higher rated player you facing
this so I kind of like what but now that
I have some Ken West prep because I've
seen this gammy maybe next time I'll
play Knight to c6 go D ready yeah
so the point here is okay maybe I'm just
gonna play e5 and immediately at some
point maybe I'm going to get my Bishop
out you know on your knight and maybe I
can play d5 at some point and also about
c6 you just can't play as a robot and go
III Bishop b3 because you can get you
back then you kick him mm-hmm
right because this is sort of an unusual
move I don't know what times you've come
across I want to stop and think but yeah
when they do put their knight in front
of their pawn there are some some
differences the knight is only useful
here if I ever play e5 if I never play
e5 then I'm in the way because if I put
my pawn on e6 and then my pawns are
going this way I need to be able to play
the move c5 and then the knight is in
the way so unless I play e5 this isn't
where I want my knight so so you just
played III because again what just does
that no matter what but okay also
possible is just Bishop f4 it's just a
little bit more active and it's the love
there on e5 every time the Grand
Master's through the analysis for this
they go when you play III they go get
the bishop up ya know you're gonna play
the callee right so against a normal
setup I mean okay III is rough
Tuesday used to be beginner breakdown
and then Mike could like get really mad
this pond was in the way but okay this
is perfectly fine and I've seen you
reading every colleague book there it
possibly is you think it would help yeah
you get through some openings pretty
good I guess this one is this is quite
an interesting variation but can with
III it can't be like portable um now he
played here so again I think maybe
Bishop g4 just with the idea of I mean
I'm trying to play you five so I have to
pin your night and and with the g4 move
in the other variations were black plays
g4 this move the Knights not on c6 so
you can write h3 Bishop to h5 g for that
Bishop there then the knight jumping
right there but with that night there
it's just like oh my gosh right this
kids drives me crazy
um is this the kid - yeah she's ready I
think all right let's get seeking you
can be 50% of eight-year-olds right so
that's only only as you see if he helps
help you help this game if he makes the
right move in this game of just an
efficient alright yeah we will get to
that very exciting moment
but until then okay you played
reasonably well we got some pieces out
just a very good I think feel like this
is kind of a wasted move probably should
just Castle or move the Queen and you
know Queen you see them Queenie Stefan
or you should cancel or something like
that but uh
wow these both wolves were given exclam
who annotated this game exclam castles x
glam castles exclusive cash for now
let's see who and dated this that's
great
it doesn't tell me it's too far away off
the screen but yeah there's probably
it's probably Josh yeah so we just
walked in the room X lamb X clam all
right
that's Grandmaster analysis right there
low rate point lower rated players
Castle yeah I know it's the most amazing
movie I've ever seen but here you did
play a great move yeah I think you
sensed that it was time to play the
movie for which is the goal that the
callee you you go slow you it's hard to
make opening mistakes you get the bishop
III bring the night to D - and then you
go E for yep and you you got to live
your dream so okay you should probably
take that because it's a pretty even
high rated player sometimes they just
ignore that just a gag if you fork them
yeah it's all just somebody just did
that in the club - and it's like like
2001 so yeah it does get missed yeah but
uh okay and then you can't help but
trade a little bit more so I can think
the opening has been a success you know
it's been a pretty good opening here
a mysterious rope deep Brook move yeah
it's s beyond my comprehension I don't I
guess you're sitting at rook on c3
I mean that this is going to happen at
some point or something otherwise he
could have done what Ken West did and he
could put his rook here and then move
his knight around that he could have
done what you did and now I thought long
and hard at this move and I and I'd like
is it work does it work
well if it should work I need to really
have a plan mm-hm on e5 probably for it
to work and I look for ten minutes of my
god just take the pawn okay and the pond
he's referring to hopefully some people
have thought about it we got our little
little trio of pieces here so we begin
to think about possible Greek gifts and
can says he couldn't help himself and he
went for it um and it was really
ill-advised it was ill-advised science
the right move but he helped me up by
not finding right move okay and yeah so
this actually it's kind of why what I
wanted to focus on here is this is when
Greek sacrifices work and when they
don't okay so he takes because I mean if
you don't accept them okay I just want
that pawn and so okay you always bring
your knight in and in this position
there's always four moves which seems
daunting but usually one or two of them
are just you just easily eliminate them
well for example going back to here just
like really easy I mean so that's you
know hardly any calculation also
whenever they go here and your Bishop is
on this line that's almost never right
you're going to click Edit yeah at least
at least this
is good unless you have something better
so there's really only two moves to even
calculate more than a couple seconds
here and there you know they can be
difficult and so you got kind of
fortunate that your opponent went to the
wrong square well but we'll test the
audience which square should you go to
here with the black king g6 exactly yeah
you should go to g6 we'll come right
back to this let's check out the game
because from here
he did play fantastic he found the maid
from here in this position black best
move is to take this Knight but by
that's and then you don't get made it
immediately but you're playing through
material yeah and in this position this
is actually a well known mating five and
you played it correctly so that was good
so so maybe I'm great so maybe you are
yeah so this actually if you've seen a
lot of Greek gift games when the rope
they get into this position and then
they move the rook over that there's
always just a mate in five and em can
went right for it so he played great he
took and now this check
now you force them away checkmate
so a fantastic finish it worked really
well again it's really pretty on paper
but if you looks good yeah it's very
aesthetically pleasing that's an awesome
name I think it's let's just look at it
for a while to give people at home a
chance to yeah you frame it the Hall of
Fame they have a big thing tomorrow
maybe we'll just bring this over but if
he goes to g6 mm-hmm it's so yeah I'm
playing down with Bishop for a pawn Oh
like I say I thought didn't it's and I'd
like I'm going for it and I think the
plan is well he's only 600 maybe you
don't work even if it doesn't work and
there is sort of a general rule to that
I've sort of noticed about this okay so
when they take away your most active
square you need to go to the next most
active player threatening his cover and
he has a simple pawn move that kills the
whole time I'm down Bishop purple so as
a general rule too if black can kick the
Queen off of the G file then this
normally doesn't work right so here as
he said it's a simple pawn move and the
Queen has to move away from the G files
so there's notice
cover is and there's no more you can't
go to h-file the rook comes over then
and I showed this to him at that the
game and he's like oh I could have won
yeah you could have bought so you know
if this guy isn't here then this perhaps
works because after I 5 you go back to
g3 they attack you again you go back to
g4 you know so it doesn't but that's
just sort of a general rule in these
situations when they can kick you off of
the G file on this position it probably
doesn't work and Josh Mandela this
analysis said King to g6 he said the
king must be brave let's say let's say
King g6 yeah and I'm not sure how white
continues the exalt exactly because
after I showed Timothy afterward f5 s5
yeah yep if you can kick the Queen off
then just doesn't work it just doesn't
work all right
but all right let's see what happened in
the third round so we got one more game
coming up here and you're playing
Richard Pope who gets grandmaster
lessons every week oh and you know what
he plays oh yeah this is actually this
is great yeah I should you don't know
whose which color because you he plays
to Kali
he plays the Kali too so yeah that's
great so we are we don't we haven't
established which side can West is in
this game but uh he would had the black
pieces okay and you played this line in
the opening there was like a little
opening trap sort of to kind of happened
here I don't know if it's even the best
but it kind of happened here so this is
kind of nice so since you can get away
with the move like this then things are
pretty good and oftentimes too white
we'll just wait which makes the most
wait for you to go to here or something
so that I could go after your Bishop
that's another this is another common
approach because when you put your
Bishop outside the pawn chain maybe I
can go after it and you know so this is
sort of a very dynamic position that
could also occur in these types of
positions but instead of c4 he decided
to go with the move
to b3 which surprised me because when I
play the Callie I never give up that
right squirt right yeah normally I don't
how can I Greek sacrifice yeah I never
take him here on the board ah so you
took and okay before we take a deeper
look at this position let me just show
you this is what he played and what did
Richard play in this position and it's a
game I know because I played it in same
position but plagued black against did I
forgot all what you can do that yeah
that happens all the time you know some
opening that you know and love is one
color but then the shoe don't chili yeah
I did I did that yeah so what did white
play in this position I'm not even sure
if the best move but because I looked in
the database just in this position good
people they just Castle we're playing to
they don't even do it on Matthew manly a
regular here at the club said he loves
playing against the variation to fight
moves off even if he loses that pawn
which we won't go into yet he loves
playing against it because he feels like
he gets several to be right and you do
right so it's going to be one of those
scenarios to give away more of a hint
where white takes a beep on and then
you'll be able to win lots of Tempe
kicking the Queen around in the future
so if you wanted to prevent let's just
show it here was the move check in the
b-pawn we won't show what Ken played yet
because we got to talk about it but then
he takes the beep on on the next move so
if you wanted to you could play the move
c6 just very solid and you know Natan
you can choose which way you want to get
your bishop out that's up to you I did
you can't get it ash lobbed shut up yeah
so it's just very solid you're playing I
guess he's a little bit higher rated so
you know some solid opening choice would
be be quite nice but he played to move
east six and in comes the check and here
I believe a mistake was made
yes so alright facing this threat so
he's thinking well I can maybe block the
check but how would you guys block here
because I think I took the wrong route I
feel like he took the wrong route so
we'll just we'll see how the audience
would have
handle disposition and they going to be
interesting Queen d7 alright then you're
here play like you're me then I go here
yes sir you have to be careful so
probably not that way because we are
anticipating that when you take care
you're on the rope
and that was played in the game so this
is this is exactly the game so well
we'll come back and see if there's a
little trap here or not and turns out
this this works out for for white so
yeah really you should just play sort of
this enroll and the reason it with the
c6 is because what he goes to takes the
be poor I want to protect the upon the
upon your rook is okay but what no but I
mean when I slide it over to okay see
okay but then you move it right away so
is that right I didn't I can't move the
room because she'll take my night with
check uh-huh and so at first I mean this
looks pretty good because I got a big
threat I'm gonna take your seat on I'm
gonna fork you it looks pretty good but
white was clever enough to find a way
out so you can pause at home I'm gonna
give it away for the live audience here
in this position white played in b5
check and now he has time to bring the
Queen back and defend the pond and now I
just play c3 and knock your knight back
and so yeah you have to you have to
worry now about this moment that's why I
did the next move so c5
yeah okay otherwise you lose tonight
yeah stuff so he did this anyway and
then here to I think he he really
mistake if he brought the Queen back in
yeah he just he couldn't help himself he
got and moved the Queen again I really
think I reuse your castle we should
develop a knight you know a she yes you
should do something else lots of things
but we can never remove your queen
around too many times in the opening I
guess so alright that was a good square
one so I'll go back that's there we get
scary yeah and even though you're down
upon I think training the Queen's here
is I think so too suppose his Queen side
developments lagging you like Mike I'm
down upon him but I could get all my
pieces in castle before he can and maybe
that will help
yeah and okay so this is the extra pawn
that you have so that's your X upon but
at least okay I get some pressure here I
can develop what I can develop Castle if
I need to put a rock on the e-file I can
maybe I can play for this break at some
moment
um it's not altogether that that bad I
mean I read ahead upon but right you
know this it's not like a full piece and
they give up playing here mm-hmm
I think to hear you made a strategic
mistake
that was quite cautious when I push the
pond yes in this position you played c4
I think really you should you should try
to develop and castle and this happens
all the time where there's this tension
in the center and part of you wants to
go here and then put this pawn here and
start doing stuff on the Queen side I
thought it would also prevent his Bishop
from just looks for Bishop for coming
out okay you're worried he would come
out this way or I don't know how does it
okay um yeah you what really happens to
when you play a move like this yeah
there's new tension it since there's no
tension it's just so much easier to play
the movie more so you you just
strategically sort of give it a little
potential for you to play e5 yeah it
won't take you to the initiative yeah so
this just didn't quite work outside I
don't particularly like that move yeah
and so he's just gonna play you for he
forward exactly yeah rook goes there you
know that's getting so again we have to
do something about this I can't read
what you did here what are you doing
here push the pause yeah that doesn't
look right
I think for better or worse you have to
go here okay so if I take with the pond
then I'm you know I might be losing this
guy sometimes so I have to worry about
everybody I think maybe if I take with a
knight and if you take you know
something like this okay so I'm down
upon but perhaps I can use this square
in the future for a knight perhaps I can
have a solid structure maybe I can you
know if you put your knight here maybe I
can even trade my Bishop for your night
I get a good night force bad fish up and
I got pressure on the Queen side you
know I'm trying to just find some some
positives or some possibility where you
might actually end up getting a good
position so I'm just I'm living I'm
dreaming here I'm like you know I see a
square like this I'm like well I kind of
want my knight here
that'll help me whenever I played b5
before it's you know I can bring my
rooks over to do stuff on the queenside
and maybe I can get some pressure get
some counter play get something going
that's kind of what you you need to do
in these types of positions because as
you know you're down upon but that
didn't happen what happened was un here
and everything is tense but eats is more
ready for it than you are right and I
think both of them both captures wind I
you played maybe the weaker of the two
this also looks very crushing I mean
you're out here on everything everything
is on everything right yeah so this
might even be more crushing but what you
did in the game is certainly find this
also as big advantage for white well
here's what make a big mistake when he
captures yeah maybe I should take that
back so yeah this is a big test so now
we're not trying to play the best move
for who can play like Canwest in this
position could pick the most big red
masterly one not deeper yeah so yeah if
you're in the 1200 range perhaps
immediately this move comes to your mind
otherwise you know if he's our nightly
this is my white night is waiting to be
taken but I'm like yeah I don't need it
yeah the moral of the story is when they
take your stuff take it back take it
back yeah hmm can anybody can west it up
right because all you can see is taking
the night bag yeah you have to ignore
that and you come up with another booth
and what do you ignore that and he
retreats the night if you look at four
grooves later you go where did I lose a
piece yeah and that takes something
don't take something you don't take
anything just make some
that would be a good move you know safe
Kings are important feta in the game he
chose the move go to the middle with the
red yes centralize your pieces and then
he just went back and yes I'm glad
somewhere you lost a piece and I didn't
realize a three moves later I look and I
can't wait a minute
he's got an extra firewood I didn't
realize we'd went over it wait later I
said what did I lose the piece he goes
right here what no and I mean you would
be surprised how many times I do see
this though but when they take your
piece you have to use SAP yeah it
doesn't matter what's happening here
stuff you know some other bad stuff
might be happening you might be losing
all these pawns or something but you
have to take it back so I think if here
- probably you could even set up a
little trick I can go here and hope that
you do this and I take here that's a
little trick I can hope for so I gotta
have a little hope so yeah I think here
if you even if he goes for the I mean
this should be bad because I don't know
I don't know maybe I can play here or
something but um so it's bad but however
bad it is whatever's happening in the
center dishes we need to take the piece
exactly yeah and realize when you're
down peace no not later yes
yeah when you that it's a bad feeling I
think we've all had it at least at some
point um it's like it where'd what am i
down material oh look at the devoted an
extra minor you're like yes it'd be
really careful when you're making all
these traits that you know how much
stuff you got on the board so you just
want back um I don't know if there's
more to this game but let's just C's
yeah I got a couple little tricks you
had a couple of tricks okay alright so
we made a threat okay we're attacking
your H pawn
alright you saw it boom now drop the
hammer now you gotta come over here I'll
shot alright not sure if I believe it
but I should be able to win the piece
spec but they didn't follow up on that
either okay yeah I don't believe it so I
take it um your your point is you check
me I check okay I don't actually member
what happened here um now I should push
the pot she pushed
Farmar yeah but I didn't so I'm gonna
move somewhere I'll tell you I'll tell
you in a second I'll tell you this thing
interesting and what if what if I just
really retreat
do I have to care what's happening here
so what are you doing I just want to see
what what's the idea here
bring the other rookie just yeah just
bring your Rick in and your tack is so
powerful yeah I got all these morphe
black pieces I've got all pieces of the
game he's got two sitting out I say cuz
if you like morphe then you want to stay
here at 7:30 cuz oh good been Feingold
has some working games to show okay um
and maybe this won't be among them
but he played here uh Tex tonight
so he defended his night and took more
of your stuff right I check check
sounds good you got you got least
something back and it's a little chaotic
but I think he he managed to navigate
through these right slight slightly
murky complications
okay ready to move was there anything
else beyond this uh yeah
I got trade bishops now he gets back
okay so he forced the trade that's good
I'm up a night and I got three on zero
right but I still had some play in this
believe it or not you still have to play
yeah okay let's just zip through it all
right yeah we were just talking about
you I'll to this game yesterday
did you give some deep insight into this
position yeah weights up tonight
connected yeah um and then he's gonna
make a queen but you can check on them
that's cool well I thought I thought
this was mate totally overlooked about
thank you me he just sax the rook well I
did points and then huff if he can't
sack the rook I'm doing pretty well
let's roll
three well yeah Deadeye you were
thinking here is checkmate but it's not
well I do I do the night was they're all
so cute
well k2f I mean rook to F I mean a tie
you can do extry extry okay I got the
leash Eric wins that's okay we love it
yeah right and also the move that he
played was more spectacular hey rook
takes pawn and my job
takes the pawn my god oh you kiddin yeah
the way you take back it's check and he
made a queen right um
I guess in any check so here it's over
as if it wasn't weren't before
okay well so that was three Ken West
game skills were a lot of fun like we
think we learned a lot here tonight it
was so for like 10 seconds I couldn't
yeah I know um what's also funny just so
some grandmasters too because I always
have to annotate the games and I don't
think Ken West's even though the worst
suspect at this but they come in and
someone just get angry and they like
can't annotate these games you know
they'll put like maybe one move or one
comment and like I just can't watch it
but they come in and they're like
complaining to me like this didn't
happen did it this isn't a chess game
right they didn't play this but those
are legitimate games they all happens if
they happens right here in the Knights
so thank you very much Ken less for
preciate a part of this great right here
you
you